well another season of euphoria has come
and gone but don't worry we only have to
wait until 2024 for new episodes i just
wanna die
yes if you're looking for an ending with
more filler than faze lips have i got
one for you i'm kidding this season was
amazing and i'm pretty sure i'm gonna
need some sort of euphoria's anonymous
to help me break this addiction if
you've never seen one of my videos
before we go really in depth into the
season lots of analysis not just recap
and of course a healthy dose of
oh a memes ambulance call an ambulance
but not for me
so come and trauma bond with me as we
dissect this season what it could mean
for season three and make sure to give
me a hit of serotonin by clicking that
like and subscribe button ah fesco the
drug dealer with a heart of gold over
the course of the season we've seen him
develop a relationship with roo's former
best friend lexi howard i wonder what
his grandmother would say
one instinct i can't trust but that's
exactly what's happened to fez forming
an unlikely relationship with lexi who
he has developed genuine feelings for
and you know as soon as he starts
talking about his dreams of starting a
family and owning a farm like in little
house on the prairie something bad is
about to happen his friend custer has
been working undercover for the police
trying to get fez to confess for the
murder of notorious drug dealer mouse a
murder which was actually committed by
fez's younger brother ashtray his
nickname came about when he would eat
cigarette butts while in the kitchen
sink tub it's kinda ironic then that
ashtray's final moments are also in a
tub ashtray's impulsiveness to protect
his family was set up back in season one
we've seen just how far he'll go to
protect those he loves and this is
exactly what happens when he stabs
custer in the throat not knowing that
the police were listening in on the
other end this is one of many examples
on the show of how love trumps reason
and almost every character on the show
gives into it even though as vez's
grandmother said it's the one instinct
you can't trust
aren't you afraid people are gonna look
down on you
[Music]
at least
love makes us do crazy things like stay
with an abusive partner betray your best
friend and to the extreme even commit
murder you may have also noticed that
ashtray has no dialogue this episode he
is a secondary character given little to
no autonomy and that's the point one of
the main themes this season is how
trauma is like a wave it ripples outward
affecting other people in ways we may
never see or notice in season one fez
cal and lexi were more secondary
characters but that doesn't mean trauma
doesn't affect them as much as any of
the others in this season we get to see
that manifest the whole point of lexi's
play is that she gets to reclaim her
voice making her the main character and
the others merely supporting just look
at how rue is billed as supporting
actress here yet on the show she's the
main character ashtray's decision to
lock himself in the bathroom and take on
the police i would argue is a decision
made out of love he is putting his
brother above himself knowing that if
they did the rational thing and turn
themselves in it would essentially mean
fez's life is over and ashtray would
lose the only family he's ever had
ashtray does not want to be abandoned
just like he was abandoned as a baby
that's his worst fear and one he'll do
anything to protect himself from i also
love this juxtaposition between ashtray
and the tub and cassie both hiding from
the consequences of their actions
actions spurred by love the difference
here was cassie's was one of selfish
love while ashtrays was one of selfless
faye custer's girlfriend knows about the
sting operation against fez but she's
developed a friendship with fez and
knows that he's a good person she
purposely drops a glass to tell fez not
to talk and even sets up lori as mouse's
killer this is one of those unresolved
plot points of the season rue owes lori
thousands of dollars for agreeing to
sell some of her product but if lori
somehow gets pinned for the murder of
mouse it may solve rue's debt at the end
of episode 207 nate stormed off after
the character he's based off in lexi's
play performed the greatest [ __ ]
themed high school musical number put to
stage nate's sexuality has been
something that's been questioned by not
only himself but those at school since
it was discovered he had a treasure
trove of dick pics on his phone he's
been made a mockery of and takes out his
frustration on cassie howard lexi's
sister for not informing him of her
sister's blatant attack on his character
it's so bad that nate tells cass to pick
up her things and move out cassie has
had a huge shift this season going from
one of the most empathized characters in
season one to villain well that makes me
a villain
then so [ __ ] beer
the end of season one saw cassie go
through with an abortion an abortion
largely pushed upon her by her
ex-boyfriend mckay mckay never made her
feel love nor did her drug-addicted
father so she seeks it out even if it
means in the most toxic of places like
nate jacobs the ex of her best friend
maddie the beginning of season 2 sees
her in one of the most vulnerable states
which leads to nate picking her up and
the two engaging in dirty party bathroom
sex the secret of hooking up with her
best friend's ex is something that eats
away at her the entire season not to
mention nate's womanizing attitude which
sees him play both women going from cast
to maddie like a fuckboy yo-yo all these
emotions culminate in a total breakdown
for cassie when she storms the stage of
her sister's play a play that recreates
embarrassing scenes from her life like
when she orgasmed on the merry-go-round
in front of everyone what becomes a play
about their lives turns into their lives
actually played out on stage as many of
our characters air out their grievances
wait is this [ __ ] play about us
maddie even chases down cassie to beat
the [ __ ] out of her i watch you fake
oh no guys who let elliot in well after
about three minutes of john mayer over
here this scene is really about roo
forgiving elliott for ratting her out
and thanking him for saving her life
i think you might have accidentally
saved my life if season one was all
about rue dealing with sobriety after a
near fatal overdose season two is all
about the relapse we see how her
addiction leads to the destruction of
almost all of her friendships she pushes
away those that love her most to protect
herself from the feeling of loss the
loss that she experienced when her
father died of cancer what's a bigger
feeling than love
loss
getting high allows rue to live without
the fear of the good moments coming to
an end and this feeling is the true root
of her addiction
the beautiful thing about getting high
is time ceases to exist i mean you can
just stay in the good moments without
the fear that they'll come to an end in
rue's final scene with lexi roo realizes
that her and lexi aren't that different
both of them have experienced similar
traumas both have lost their fathers
although in two different ways but lexi
has channeled her trauma through art
i don't know how to get to where you are
if lexi can get to a place of relative
peace that means there's hope for rue as
well
the hope
is what roo has to find rue doesn't want
to hold on to this pain forever she
needs to find some sort of release so my
guess for season three is that rue will
be looking for that reason while i do
think she'll be tempted by drugs in
upcoming seasons there are far more
captivating stories to be told about her
other than rehashing another relapse so
expect her character to go through some
massive changes whether or not roo and
elliot will remain friends is unclear he
said multiple times throughout the
season that he's not good for her it
also depends on how far of a time jump
we'll have in season 3 but we'll get
into that in a bit lexi thinks her show
is a disaster
it's the only thing i've ever done and
it's a disaster but rue being the good
friend that she is starts a chant to get
the show on the road i also gotta say i
love lexi's attention to detail here
look at ethan who's playing as nate's
character with his forehead brews
mimicking the one nate got after being
beat up by fez lexi is also super
assertive and dominant in her role as
director part of her character arc this
season is finding the courage to stick
up for herself and take control of her
own life she's always been so passive
now she never had the courage to say
anything with her play she has found
part of that courage to do what she
wants regardless of the consequences
nate has gone to visit his dad who left
their home in what can only be described
as a disgustingly epic fashion that's
standing in the foyer with his dick out
in episode 203 we see how cow's life was
shaped by one event his girlfriends and
soon-to-be wife's pregnancy because of
that he married her and became trapped
never getting to explore his sexuality
or what his life could have been over
years this festered into toxic
resentment i have a problem
but the reason i have a problem is this
family he had to lead a secret life one
in which he'd hook up with men and trans
women in hotel rooms and secretly film
them part of nate's messed up childhood
stemmed around his father's secrets at
age 11 nate found his dad's sex videos
and there's no telling what kind of
traumatic effect that had on him it's
part of the reason nate wants to have a
family just so that he can spite his
father by showing him how he can raise a
child and for it not to be [ __ ] up
like all of them it's why nate has an
entire dream sequence depicting cassie
pregnant living the perfect life nate
like his father is bitter and resentful
you don't get to ruin our lives
and just
move on and get to be happier i spent my
whole life trying to protect you
and instead of loving me you [ __ ]
hated me for it nate has had enough and
calls the police having shown them his
father's collection of secret videos
some with underage partners like jules
in episode 206 nate said part of the
reason he wouldn't turn in his dad was
that he was set to take over his
father's business and no one really
wants to buy houses from the son of a
pedo but something has changed this time
not only does nate turn him in but he
also gives jules what he says is the
only copy of the recording nate has been
absolutely terrible to jewels throughout
these two seasons both blackmailing and
assaulting her so it's only reasonable
that jules questions his motivations for
giving her the recording nate responds
honestly the answer is too stupid and
simple too stupid and too simple the
answer's gotta be love mixed with a
healthy dose of revenge against his
father i don't want your apology
i just want revenge look nate said
everything he told jules about his
feelings towards her when they were
online dating were true but nate's also
a piece of [ __ ] so who knows ashtray is
killed by the swat team or at least
that's what is heavily implied the last
shot of him is of a target laser on his
forehead before we hear a shot go off
fez is also shot but considering he's
one of the most popular characters on
the show i think he'll be back but will
fez go to prison his fingerprints are on
custer's murder weapon and he did own
these weapons which gotta be illegal but
honestly it's much more of a gray area
and with ashtray getting killed i think
it actually opens up more opportunities
for fez to get off they could easily say
it was ashtray who killed custer and who
knows where those weapons came from they
could be custers for all we know there's
also a great juxtaposition here when roo
talks about how she was in the hall when
her dad died as we see fez in the hall
as ashtray is killed she says this is
the scene that scars her forever we have
moments in our life that traumatize and
shape us into who we are for fez this
will definitely be one of those with rue
asking to come over to lexi's and their
heartfelt talk combined with the last
line of lexi's play being i miss you it
wouldn't be a stretch to see lexi and
roo rekindle their friendship in season
three especially considering the last
interaction we see of rue and jewels
jules apologizes to roo and tells her
she loves and misses her roo simply
kisses her on the forehead and leaves
it's a small gesture of forgiveness but
it's also the reverse of what happened
at the end of season one instead of
jules leaving roo it's now rue leaving
jewels in the bathroom it looks like
maddie was the clear victor in their
little brawl tensions have eased and
cassie can't believe what she did
especially over a guy who just broke up
with her
don't worry
this is just the beginning maddie knows
what it's like to date nate she knows
the emotional ups and downs the breakups
and get back togethers for cassie this
is just the beginning expect nate to be
back in cassie's world for better or
worse in the show's final scene we get
more narration from rue narration that
hints there will be a time jump next
season she talks about how she stayed
clean for the rest of the school year so
it looks like the end of junior year is
done but just how far we will jump we
don't quite know remember that seasons 1
and 2 cover the girls junior year in
high school so season 3 might continue
with the beginning of senior year or
they may really shake things up and go
to college but i think that may be more
difficult to pull off there are still a
lot of plot points that haven't been
resolved like roo's debt to lori matty's
relationship with her employer cat's
online sex work nate's relationship with
cassie and not to mention cassie's life
in general which basically imploded and
will ethan finish that song he's still
working on bro you had that perfected
weeks ago but the season's final line
drives home the core of what euphoria
deals with each and every episode what
is it that makes a good person
the thought of maybe being a good person
is what keeps me trying to be a good
person we are all flawed individuals and
the word good is subjective for example
i think fez is a good person but he's
also a drug dealer and beat the [ __ ] out
of nate whether you think he deserved
that beating or not cass isn't sure
she's a good person i don't know if i'm
a good person
this is right after she hooked up with
her best friend's ex and nate doesn't
care at all about being good what did
you become like a good person
absolutely not no when he turns in his
father it's not about being good it's
about revenge and rue tells her dead
father in a dream sequence i'm sorry i
like it yeah
cause i'm not a good person and her
mother echoes that statement
you're not a good person room it's also
why rue likes hospitals
you know what i like about hospitals
they don't need to know how good of a
person you are in order to take care of
you this is why this end line is so
important and why rue ruminates on it
she may not be good but the thought that
she might will keep her trying if season
2 saw her reaching her low season 3 will
likely be about healing and this
sentence foreshadows that in some ways
lexi's play was a necessary evil to hold
a mirror up to her friends and loved
ones to see the destructive ways they
harm themselves and others as fez says
everybody gets their feelings hurt
you know
some people need to get their feelings
hurt sometimes some people need to get
their feelings hurt in order to grow
that's how we are as humans i am beyond
excited for what's in store for season
three the characters are compelling
because of their flawed nature and
watching them grow overcome their flaws
or succumb to tragedy is what makes the
show captivating but i want to hear what
you thought about season 2 who are your
favorite characters and what do you want
to see in season 3. thanks for watching
everyone make sure to like and subscribe
and for more bad takes you can always
follow me on twitter and instagram at
thingstoryt until next time remember
that's standing in the foyer with this
dick